hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar surveying expression
of the mune shek point markers in the
tumor micro-environment
I am Judy I'll roar collaboration I'll
be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning it
brought to you by advanced cell
Diagnostics advanced cell Diagnostics is
a world leader in RNA biomarker analysis
for precision medicine providing the
most advanced RNA analysis solutions for
cell and tissue based diagnostics and
molecular pathology its proprietary
award-winning RNA scope technology is
capable of detecting and quantifying RNA
biomarkers with single molecule
sensitivity and single cell resolution
the technology has been employed in
hundreds of peer-reviewed publications
by a rapidly growing customer base of
thousands of active users including all
the top global biopharmaceutical
companies and world leading academic
institutions the company builds
strategic alliances with its customers
and partners to develop companion
diagnostic tests for existing and
emerging therapeutics and also pursues
internal programs to develop and
commercialize proprietary cancer
diagnostic tests for more visit WWF CD
Viacom let's get started this webinar
has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits you can post questions through
the speaker during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind did you
so simply type them in Q&A box which
will open when you click the green - and
a button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left
analysis in today's speaker Jeffery chem
PhD a research scientists for R&D and
advanced cell Diagnostics dr. kim
obtained a PhD in molecular biology at
the University of Connecticut
investigating how nutrient metabolism
impacts gene expression to alter chronic
disease states afterward he completed a
postdoctoral fellowship at the
University of California Davis
looking at lancôme metabolite metabolism
in renal cell carcinoma and the role of
da da da hexanoic acid drive and cab
lights on tumor angiogenesis he
previously completed the fellowship at
the National Institutes of Health
examining the influence of various fatty
acids on brain development by combining
the powerful tools of mass spectrometry
and imaging dr. Kim will now begin his
presentation thanks Judy hi everyone I
want to thank you for joining me today
as we discussed the expression of immune
checkpoint markers in the context of the
tumor microenvironment by now it comes
as no surprise that immune cells have an
influence in the development of cancer
hence immune monitoring is a valuable
approach in assessing in discovering
meaningful relationships and in their
actions between the host immune system
and tumor the immune system played an
important role in controlling and
eradicating cancer it's a personalized
defense system that specializes in
recognizing and attacking anything
identified as being foreign in the body
such as viruses bacteria and even the
body's own mutated cells while it is
extremely effective at clearing out
these potential harmful armful intruders
it's when cancer cells become overly
mutated to the point that the immune
system fails to recognize and kill them
that they grow unchecked in these cancer
tissues immune suppressive cytokines
molecules and cells including tear eggs
constitute the aminos repressive Network
to further inhibit effective anti-tumor
immunity thereby promoting cancer
progression this horrifically allows the
tumor cells to generate a tolerant micro
environment and activate negative
regulatory checkpoints this should all
sound quite familiar to the cancer amino
and
hypothesis put forward by Schreiber many
years back while this may all seem bleak
the blockade of immune checkpoint
molecules have changed the landscape of
eme and battlefield as with many things
a careful balance is important the case
here a balance between inhibitory
checkpoints and activating signals is
necessary to regulate an effective
immune response many cancers protect
themselves from the immune system by an
inhibiting T cell signaling such as a
circumstance of the inhibitory
checkpoint signaling of programmed death
one receptor also known as PD one by its
ligand PDL one effective therapy is
blocking PD 1 or PDL one may prevent the
down regulation of T effector cell
functions allowing T cells to maintain
and even regain their anti tumor ability
to mediate tumor cell death what this
means is that antibody therapy directed
against these negative logical
regulators these checkpoints have
demonstrated significant success and
what will likely be a major component in
patient treatment for various
malignancies clinical trials targeting
PD 1 and PDL 1 and melanoma and non
small cell lung cancer have reported
high response rates and - Miral PDL one
expression has been suggested as a
potential biomarkers you enrich for
patient response to these treatments
recent clinical trials utilizing key d1
or PBL one antibodies in melanoma non
smells the most Mon cell lung carcinoma
and renal cell carcinoma have shown
safety and durable tumor regression anti
PD one antibodies have recently been
approved for use in the United States
and other countries as IPP one
therapeutic antibody is function through
binding to PD 1 on tumor reactive T
cells thereby inhibiting the PB 1 PB l1
interaction leading to reinvigorating
the anti tumour t cell response PV l1 is
normally expressed on metaphoric
endothelial and epithelial cells in
response to inflammation and expressed
on a number of tumors including ovarian
lung real cell carcinomas which are
believed to play a major role in the
immune suppression
within the tumor microenvironment
specifically PDL one expression and
tumour cells have been shown to suppress
t cell activation and induced T cell
ptosis from this from these various
studies we know that antibody therapy is
directed against these checkpoints
fortunately war for many patients
however while we see varying levels of
success anti PD one PBL one drugs show
consistent activity across various solid
tumors however a substantial proportion
of patients show a primary resistance
and those who benefit do not benefit to
the same extent positive expression of
PBL one through immunohistochemistry has
been previously used as a screening tool
however inconsistencies and reliability
issues remain present for example some
patients demonstrating PDL one positive
tumors have no response after therapy
alternatively clinical efficacy has been
demonstrated in PBL one negative tumors
and other patients so why do we see this
variation using immunohistochemistry
they fall on the use of non specific
antibodies inconsistent cut-offs
including mutable definitions for
positivity and tissue preparation and
processing in many antibody trials
simply looking at clinical outcomes
rather than evaluating actual immune
responses has made it difficult to know
how to improve the approach one of the
many things one must consider are the
antigens present to accomplish this a
cell specific and sensitive approach is
indispensable to tease out these
previously used response parameters to
have been quite incongruent in order to
bring meaning to the data I will present
you today allow me to provide a brief
introduction to the technical approach
so that we may appreciate the data and
see how it can be utilized in furthering
our understanding of immune checkpoint
markers first let's discuss the RNA
scope technology the technology behind
the RNA scope ich esse has three main
advantages over conventional gene
expression analysis methods one
it generates a very high signal
amplification with suppression of
background compared to tradition a ish -
it can detect signal RNA molecules and
sit in single cells with morphological
context unlike Grendon by methods such
as PCR and 3 it's universal yes it can
detect virtually any gene and any tissue
from any species provided the sequence
is known
unlike immunohistochemistry were getting
an antibody to perform with specificity
and high sensitivity is a very
challenging prospect also if an antibody
is not available it can be very time
consuming and costly to develop one and
now here's a brief overview of the
Arnage scope method it's a slide based
assay intended for use on the same types
of samples you would use for either
immunohistochemistry or
immunofluorescence I have a
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded or
fresh or frozen fixed frozen tissue
sections or cells the RNA scope
methodology involves hybridizing the
target specific eliminating nucleotide
probes to the target RNA the target
probe is a pool of oligos that we've
designed using an established automatic
algorithm that selects sequences to
specifically bind physically to the
target sequence and not cross hybridize
with any other sequences you yielding
unparalleled such as fitting the end
result
a single target dot representing an RNA
molecule this visualization of puncay
dots allows for quantification of gene
expression because tissue samples can be
highly variable proper sample
preparation and the right controls are
essential to an RNA scope experiment
tissue samples must be properly fixed
and prepared so that there is a good
quality RNA in the sample and no
background due to poor fixation ATB
provides guidelines on house issues
should be fixed for optimal performance
for the RNA as a here are serial
sections from human lung cancer samples
on which we perform the manual read
chromogenic acid on the left is the
section stained with a may of control
probe Dappy which is a bacterial gene as
not expressed in an intact tissue as
observed in dit sample there should be
no signal from that being in the middle
panel is a section from the same sample
stained with our positive control for
the housekeeping gene PPI beam as
observed from the sample you want to see
fairly uniform detection with a positive
control probe indicating good quality
RNA certain tissues may express the
positive control probe at higher or
lower levels but in general you want to
see expression throughout the sample
with the results from these two probes
we can have confidence in the test data
we see in the right panel this is a
section from the same lung cancer sample
probe for PDL one trust me we'll see a
lot more PBO one today PDL one exhibits
a wide range of expression in tumor
tissues and it's human lung cancer
example we observe strong humpy thoughts
with PDL one probe and sample the
controls show us that there is good
quality RNA throughout the tissue sample
and that there is little to no
background so we can be confident that
the localized pattern of expression we
observe for PDL one is in fact the true
selection of the biology of the tumor
and here is an image of a non small cell
lung carcinoma sample what should be
focused on the study presented to you
momenta momentarily evident in the above
in
and throughout the study who observed a
great deal of inter tumor heterogeneity
four of all markers in almost all tumor
samples starting from the left hand side
the expression of PBL one is until it
expressed and most the cells as a high
amount going toward the center we see
that when we cross the middle divide
across the stroma PDL one expression is
higher than the first region and slowly
diminish further into the tumor
you'll also notice little pockets of PBL
one that I also scattered throughout the
tumor region non small cell lung
carcinoma is the leading cause of
cancer-related mortality worldwide
whilst treatment has been dramatically
improved in patients who Harbor
targetable genomic alterations such as
EGFR only a minority of small non small
cell lung carcinoma patients benefit
from these targeted agents immunotherapy
approaches such as PD 1 and PDL 1
blockades appear to be broadly
efficacious and non small cell lung
carcinoma patients for this Emilia
Oncology application we had a CDS R&D
team conducted study on non small cell
lung carcinoma to evaluate tissue
expression in immune checkpoint markers
and immune functions in the tumor
microenvironment we selected 60 FFP
tissue blocks from non small cell lung
cancer patients these 60 tissue blocks
were already screened and TG passed for
RNA quality by using the positive
control probe P P IV and the negative
control probe that beam out of the 60
course 56 for tumor tissues and four
were found to be adjacent non tumor
tissues out of those 56 tumor cases
pathological evaluation indicated that
26 cases were squamous cell carcinoma 22
or adenocarcinoma and eight were a
combination the fixed e tissue samples
were arranged as a tumor microarray on
two slides as depicted in this schematic
illustration here yellow circles
indicate tumor tissues while white
circles indicate adjacent non tumor
tissues we first evaluated the pv1 gene
expression profile
using the RNA scope single plug class a
followed by evaluate evaluating Koch
expression profiles of PDL one with one
other checkpoint marker or immune
function marker in the tumor
microenvironment by using the RNA scope
duplex at same here it's overview of PBL
one expression in selected p.m. a course
PBL 1m r and it shown here as red dots
in some of the team a course such as the
NOPD a one example black depositions of
M periodic pigment were present which is
an accumulation of carbon acquired from
the environment these dark deposits
should not be confused with the RNA
specific signal in the expected course
dynamic range of PDL one gene expression
is visualized from high medium low to no
PDL one expression in the various tumor
course in some adjacent non-tumor course
we see a we observed rare PDL one
positive cells likely representing
antigen presenting cells the negative
controls that be probe in serial
sections of the same tissue showed no
background across all sections RNA scope
data can be analyzed by both a semi
quantitative and qualitative methods
with a semi quantitative method a score
is assigned to a sample based on the
average number of dots per cell shown
here at the top is the semi quantitative
scoring system that ATV have generated
for the essay while a score of 0 has no
staining or less than one dot for every
ten cells a score for has greater than
fifteen dollars per cell this method
will be used to provide a general
understanding of the results later on we
will look at data analyzed using an
automated approach but for now on to the
data
this again is a schematic overview of
PBL one expression of all 60 course
numbers in each circle represents the
score is generated by the manual
counting which is explained previously
among the 56 tumors issues 82% were
found to be PBL one positive with scores
of 1 or higher consistently for two
independent experiments 56% of the
tumour showed media to high levels of
tumor PPO and expression with scores of
two or higher which is also tested in
two independent experiments overall the
study demonstrates a high percentage of
PDL 1 positive tumors in this subset of
non-small cell lung carcinoma patients
this number is higher than previously
reported cases this may be attributed by
the fact that the RNA scope assay has
high sensitivity compared to you in
media history chemistry additional ink
this can simply be a reflection of a
unique environmental status in this
subset of patients next using the RNA
scope duplicate a thing we then
evaluated the expression landscape of
other checkpoint markers in combination
with PBL 1 in serial sections of PMA
this table here shows the distribution
of tissue tumor tissues expressing these
8 additional markers including immune
inhibitory checkpoint markers such as pd
1 PDL to lag 3 ctla-4 Tim 3 and b 7 h 4
aisle 10 a cytokine marker and the
immune stimulatory molecule for 1bb
analytes together with PDL 1 the
expression pattern was represented by
percentage of tissues with corresponding
RNA scope scores for example 54 percent
of tissues showed low PD one expression
with scores of one while 52% tissues
showed high team 10 3 expression with
score the 3 from this table we see that
many tumors expressed high levels of
cpeli 4 and 10 3 al 10 and P 1
expression were relatively low in most
tumor course I'll now show you the
expression profiles of these various
checkpoint markers and selected tissue
cores shown in this table these cores
were ranked from high to low PDL one
electrician from top to bottom
in court qe2 or PBL one is expressed at
very high levels we also observed high
level expression for PDL to flag three
ppl a for Tim three and four one BB in
course 1 B 1 and 2 D 1 where PDL 1 is
expressed high with scores of 3 the core
expression profile of the other markers
between the 2 cores were variable
especially with b7h 4 in course 1 P 1
and 1a 2 were moderate levels of PDL 1
was expressed with scores of two
variations of other markers between
cores were also jerk especially with
like 3 and finally in chorus 1 B 3 1 F 3
1 B 5 and 2 C 3 a 4 a little to no PDL 1
was expressed
markers are found to be expressed in a
heterogeneous manner overall what this
tells us is that there are complex and
heterogeneous Koch expression profiles
of various checkpoint markers in the
tumor the information presented here
brings potential interesting insights on
therapeutic approaches for example with
tumors such as QE 2 and core 1 b1 which
show high levels of PDL 1 and GPA for
respond better with combination therapy
or with tumors like 1 B 3 and 2 C 3
still represents so be responsive to
other checkpoint inhibitors
even though little to no PDL 1 is
expressed since each tumor is clearly
exhibiting varying expression profiles
of these markers it goes without saying
that each patient could experience
different successes if given the same
therapy
here we have snapshot core one b3 which
shows low to no PBL one expression since
these TMA's were serial sections similar
regions can be compared side by side we
find here that there's little to no
little expression of PDL one with PD one
PDL two and four one BB in these
selected regions while moderate
expression of blackberry and temporary
and finally strong ctla-4 expression
what's found in the stromal regions in
contrast we have Co expression snapshot
of core 2 a2 e2 here which shows high
overall PDL one expression from this
serial section tumor region we observe
that PDL one is shown in teal while all
other markers are shown in red we find
that ppl 1 and P BLT are both expressed
in tumor and stromal regions and Koch
expressed in the same cells which they
are indicated by the black arrows ctla4
for one BB PD one lagg-3 and Tim 3 were
expressed primarily in stromal regions
and lastly lack 3 and temporary are
co-expressed with PDL one in various
cells
the following slides are zoomed in
images of each Koch expression profile
from the same core quarto to e2 here
again we have Co expression of PBL one
with PD one where we see PBL one
expressed primarily in tumor cells in
the Katyn teal and pd1 expressed in
lymphocytes passing through the stromal
regions in red
next we show Co expression of PDL 1 and
PBL 2 where we see both pd-1 litems
expressed primarily in tumor cells here
we have Co expression of PBL one with
ctla-4 where we see PBL 1 express
primarily in tumor cells and GPL a 4 on
lymphocytes in the stroma
similarly co-expression of PDL 1 and
lagg-3 observed here where we see PBL
one expression again primarily in tumor
cells while lag 3 is found in the
lymphocytes again in the stromal region
and finally we observed Co expression of
PDL 1 and 10 3 where we see PBL one
expression predominantly in tumor cells
and 10 theory expression on lymphocytes
Co expression is again observed in
various cells infiltration by
lymphocytes into the tumor region as
well as depicted by Tim 3 expression
from these Co expression profiles it is
quite clear that tumors are again
heterogeneous and that no two tumors are
identical in comparison the EC tumor in
comparison between these acute imitates
is lagg-3 which is expressed in both
tumor and thermal regions in court 1 b1
but primarily in a stromal compartment
in core 2 e 2 10 3 however was expressed
almost mutually exclusively with PDL 1
and core 1 b1 but Co expressed in
various cells in court to e2 PDL 2 was
primarily expressed in stroma and core 1
b1 but also expressed in both normal and
tumor regions in the court to e2 moving
forward
next I want to show you another way of
analyzing the data if the investigation
requires a quantitative component to
draw
conclusions in a falling leaf will be of
interest rnh Sophia can be analyzed in
the more objective and rapid manner
using an automated software analysis
platform such as indica labs halo
software in order to speed up the
process of counting the number of
thoughts or events in each cell halo was
used to assign regions set of parameters
and process the data this will make more
sense in just a minute for the analysis
of the inhibitory checkpoint markers PDL
1 and lagg-3 we designated two different
regions of interest
these included the stromal and the tumor
regions efficiently the entire core was
also processed so that a comparison to
the remainder of the tissue core could
be demonstrated these regions here
identified as layers where yellow areas
represent stromal regions green areas
that I need to myrrh regions and the
entire core within the red perimeter
surrounding the cell and here are the
results
this analysis demonstrates that like 3
and core 1b one was found primarily in
the stromal region while the tumor
reasons showed a lower expression PDL
one reflected in the inverse
relationship which is biologically sound
as PBL one is expressed primarily on the
surface of tumors the strength of this
approach is that region specific target
expression can be identified as well as
counted one point that I would like to
mention is that the quantitation of
lagg-3
and PDL one from the overall core again
here in red showed that both checkpoint
markers were expressed at equal levels
however it is clear from this analysis
that this is not the case as life the
expression was higher in stromal regions
and PDL one expression was found to be
higher in the tumor regions having the
capability to now analyze samples along
with morphological contexts permit such
interpretation which is not made
possible with the tip of
grindin by nasa's which masks the sight
of expression now however if you want to
compare two different course well for
the analysis of the FC course we use the
same designated regions the thermal and
tumor regions as well as the entire core
based off of our previous manual count
core 1v1 was found to have high
expression of PVL one while core 2d one
had lower expression this translated to
is translated through our quantitative
analysis here producing a meaningful
checkpoint expression profile output
while lagg-3 was expressed primarily in
a stromal compartments with a reduction
in the tumor regions it is quite obvious
at a higher number of cells in a tomb in
the Strobel region expressed lagg-3
and core won't be one compared to chord
3d one in a similar vein PDL one was
highest in tumor regions for both course
while lagg-3 was expressed primarily on
lymphocytes received expression and
tumor regions indicating the presence of
lymphocytes infiltrating into the tumor
regions the strength of this analysis is
that the expression of different markers
can be compared directly between two
cores which represents biopsy samples
from this it is evident that Co
expression is an occurrence that may
influence the outcome of checkpoint
blockade therapy and that Co expression
is is an important aspect of determining
the applicability of immune checkpoint
therapy despite course 1 b1 + 2 e 2
expressing a similar quantity of PDL 1
as well as m3 in lack 3 the strength of
this RNA scope as it can be appreciated
here we compare Co expression between
the two cores with core to e 2 having
greater number of PDL 1 and PDL
- of expression even within the same
core co-expression can be quite
heterogeneous in the schematic diagram
to the top left hand side we see PD 1
and temp 3 expressed on two different
lymphocytes alternatively both
inhibitory checkpoint molecules can be
expressed on a single cell the image
below reflects this occurrence PD 1
until is expressed on various cells as
of Tim 3 in red however we observed
co-expression several instances
indicated by the arrows a recent
publication reveals this aspect and
targeting specific immune checkpoints in
the case of lung tumors adaptive
resistance to anti PD one treatment
developed resulting in the up regulation
of Tim 3 and PD one antibody found T
cells what this suggests is that the up
regulation of 10 3 and other immune
checkpoints may be targetable biomarkers
associated with adaptive resistance to
PD one blockade the takeaway from this
revelation is that the immune checkpoint
landscape isn't as cut and dry and drug
resistance must be considered during
therapy in order to evaluate the
appropriate approach regarding
immunotherapy the Co expression of
multiple immune checkpoints in the tumor
microenvironment must be assessed for an
effective means of attack to summarize
the study the expression profiles of
immune checkpoint and functional markers
were evaluated in humour
microenvironment of 60 and SCLC FFPE
tissues by RNA scope a large proportion
of non-small cell lung cancer faces who
are identified as PDL 1 positive by RNA
scope scoring either in tumor cells
and/or normal cells over 50% of cases
showed PDL one expression in both tumor
and normal cells
the detection of co-expression profiles
of mobile checkpoint markers in the
tumor microenvironment revealed a
heterogeneous pattern of expression in
different tumor tissues as well as
injured tumor heterogeneity
this information may reveal potential
insight into combination therapies
targeted against different checkpoint
pathways the bottom line from this
investigation is that there's a great
need for more biomarkers to be tested in
combination to gauge patient response
and with that I would like to a festival
at ACV ATV is a biotech company with a
goal in mind to facilitate various arms
of research whether it be in a
diagnostic or clinical setting or even
the academic realm the idea is that our
technology will be to be able to enable
researchers to make progress and their
research goals
so with that I'd like to turn it back to
Gd well thank you dr. Kim for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
dr. Kim will answer as many questions as
time permits and first question is with
diversity in the tumor cells how can we
make sure that Jam a can reflect all
phenomenons in the tumor nodule as you
could say one more time yeah sure
with diversity in the tumor cells how
can we make sure that PMA can reflect
all phenomenons in the tumor nodules
that's a good question I think by
answering home you can of course
encompass everything at once so you have
to have specific markers that you're
interested in to identify I guess your
target that you're mainly interested in
so that's the kind of a vague or broad
explanation but if you have a specific
marker in mind or specific cell type or
a functional marker in mind you need to
use that marker and
probe it together it has to see if
there's Coke expression would it be
possible to check those RNA scope and
ihd staining on samples from same
patient of sanitation to evaluate the
correlation and has advanced cell
Diagnostics had done that oh that's
another excellent question
so yes we are currently in the works of
comparing antibodies and using our
technology at the same time we haven't
released that information that's because
it's actually still ongoing but that's a
very important question that we get
asked I think as much often many times
so coming soon ten multiple fluorescent
dyes be applied in a safe to detect
markers once oh yes we also have a
multiplex assay where you can combine at
the moment with confidence three
different markers at once and doing so
would enable you to look at all three
markers at the same time within the same
region of the same tissue
it's the variation of checkpoints tumor
types specific or more likely individual
specific sorry you say one more time
sure it's the variation of checkpoint
tumor type specific or more likely
individual specific hmm that question I
cannot answer I'd say both situations
can be true yeah that one is too hard to
tell please help compare this technology
with classic immunohistochemistry tissue
array operation time spending or cost
oh sorry because here warmest handle now
together that single oh absolutely
please help compare this technology with
classic immunohistochemistry tissue
array operation time spending or cost um
so a typical RNA tasks opacity it
depends on if you're doing a single flex
or duplex a single flex can take around
78 hours from start to finish so it can
be done in one day and that gives you a
lot of information you have the
morphological context of the tissue as
well as you can have all the various
targets that you're interested in and
the beauty of this our national platform
is that you can have any target in mind
from as long as you have a sequence we
can have a pro for you ready in two
weeks and we had some guarantee that it
will it would be specific and indicates
or targets the probe that you're most
interested in
well image analysis of TMA scores done
with her course I'm sorry with image
analysis of TM a course done with halo
software yes and that was used with
indica labs halo software how many
markers can I stain at the same time for
the same areas and cells um so the
depend on which after you choose if
you're going with the traditional chroma
Jenna gasps a you can go through use two
and two added two probes at the same
time however if you want to use a
fluorescence approach and you can
combine an up to three at the moment and
more questions may be coming in but in
the meantime I would just like to ask
you I would like to thank you for your
presentation and I would like to ask if
you have any final comments for us today
this is a great opportunity to discuss
its recent study that we here at APD
conducted and I think the beauty of this
is that it kind of reveals to
researchers and anyone looking at
are interested in looking at the tumor
microenvironment in great detail you can
do various targets at the same time so I
think that has a lot of waste and can
actually push forward of the research
significantly well thank you
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions and we would also
like to thank our sponsor advanced cell
Diagnostics for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webinar has
been approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the C e button
at the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits this
webcast can be viewed on-demand through
December 30th 2016 lab routes will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time bye